you know it's too bad it's Friday is
that big for yourself I am very excited
about the weekend ABC tells E.T today
that TJ and Amy are both officially out
at the network adding we all agree it's
best for everyone that they move on a
source ads TJ will get a payout
negotiated from his reported
seven-figure salary we've heard that
this has gotten pretty dicey and pretty
contentious reports that he's claiming
that he's being treated differently than
other anchors because of his race
clearly that's a really serious
allegation if it is true we're gonna
have to see the other facts that are
backing up his clean that this could be
race related as for Amy her settlement
is unclear but the network says we
recognize their talent and commitment
over the years and are thankful for
their contributions I think the
attorneys at the network are going to
look at Amy's case separate from TJ's
clearly they're intertwined because this
was all spurred because of the Affairs
in the eight weeks since TJ Jay and
Amy's Affair was outed by
thedailymail.com there have been new
Bombshells including accusations of Amy
drinking on the job oh what a morning it
is and showing up intoxicated for this
report on the college football national
championship last year you said that a
lot of people are waking up Champions
here if you were a Georgia Bulldog fan
some of us never went to sleep an ET
Source calls the claims absurd as GMA
conducted their investigation we're told
some employees felt uncomfortable by the
pairs flirty onset Behavior you're the
Pacer that may be the PC yeah you're the
PC okay so yeah we're gonna both be
finishers and that's what counts our
source says it's a shock to hear all the
allegations being leveled at Amy when
all she is really at fault for is
falling for her colleague TJ's co-worker
Affair account includes two other women
besides Amy the latest a junior staffer
at GMA because I'm such a marriage
component I I want everybody to get
married I do want to point out that this
case really does come down to the moral
clause in each of their contracts it's
basically a provision that employers
have a right to end your contract in the
event you do something that might
reflect badly on the company I don't
know how much this has hurt their higher
ability I do think their kind of
behavior is something that some
employers are going to be able to look
uh past and perhaps hire them for other
positions on air or elsewhere
[Music]